DotA was actually, I saw a video
for it and I said "That will be the one
Valve game I never buy. It looks stupid
and nerdy and horrible."
Where am I!?
It's all-star match, Team Slacks vs Team Kaci
You wanna do this for real?
Kaci: Oh you want a piece of this? Let's do this!
Slacks: Back it up.
Kaci: Give us a second, excuse me.
Slacks: UFC. Give me one sec.
Slacks: Are you satisfied?
Shopper: Uuuuuuuh...
I don't know.
Slacks: Thank you so much sir!
Slacks: Why you gotta grab it man, take it easy! "I'm Helen!"
Charlie: Remember how you looked like a retarded used
car salesmen at the major?
Slacks: Remember how I stopped giving a fuck Charlie?
Hi I'm Jake, also known as SirActionSlacks
regrettably. I should have been
ColonelQuit that was number two so
oh god that would be better.
Well I was 12, we were playing Xbox and Halo 1. Got some
homies together in my room we got a
bunch of pizzas we all decided we will come up
with our names by the time the night
ended. You know, 13 hours later after a
few cokes and a lot of pizza and that was it
man we uh, it was a close one but I got that.
Kaci: Slacks is it!? More like Skirts...
Slacks: Jesus...
I played Team Fortress 2 religiously once i got a computer...
and then a buddy of mine said, "Hey they're
giving away hats in DotA for Diretide."
And I was like, "Free hats? On it!"
Now, DotA 2 could be a very aggressive place
for a new player people don't like it
when you don't know what's going on
And there's two kinds of people, they say I don't have time for
this they move on with their lives they
become successful and happy and then
there's DotA people that say this makes me mad
I'm gonna play it till I'm the best in
the world and then they get depressed
and spend the rest of her life on it so
yeah I'm a DotA person like all the others.
And I got flamed religiously when
i first started off like most new
players, then I decided how can you flame
somebody who sounds like an idiot?
So I used to play gyrocopter I have like 500
Gyrocopter games and I'm horrible
at the hero but the entire time if
you're running around sounding like an
old confused man nobody flames you they
just laugh about.
"Hey Everybody! How's it going?
Ou wee! Oh Jesus!"
There's a lot of cursing!
Player: I'm literally way too high to listen to you right now.
Slacks: Oh my god it's pooping!
And that's how I always played. My friends were like,
"You should record yourself and post it, people might
like this." and I was like "No one's gonna like
this." and then they were mostly right yeah
most people didn't but eventually we got it working.
You know, I'm kind of the communities creation
unfortunately. I was making these dumb
videos and the power cord on my computer
broke, or the power supply
I looked it up, costs $200. I've been
poor my entire life, so I asked the
community, could you guys help me raise two
hundred dollars to get this new power
cord so i can keep making these videos
go home to work for nine hours, come back
home and on the little
two-hundred-dollar IndieGoGo there was
nine thousand dollars
so yeah, by the end of it I made almost
13 grand and I said, "Okay, not gunna waste this
i'm gonna get a new computer, i'm
going to start streaming, i'm going to
fly to TI4 and that TI4 video and
that experience is what got me really
interested in competitive DotA and then
I decided I want to do this for the rest
my foreseeable future, then there you go.
Slacks: Hi i'm here with my personal
hero the man himself and... I'm sorry who are you again?
KotLguy: How's you 'doin my friend, how's it going?
Slacks: It's going good now I'm just...
I'm just star struck!
Why did you ruin my dreams?
Soe: Uh, I don't know. I was just sitting around was like
you know what would be really cool?
Ruin someone else's dreams.
Slacks: You would do great things...
Jess: You're also a great interviewer
Slacks: Holy shit!
You heard it from here! Oh yeah we're doing great!
We're here in these very comfortable seats where my
knees are bleeding sitting in...
What  is this shit!? I'm not even huge!
Hello! I am here with a wonderful
lady by the name of...
Liz: Liz
Slacks: Oh shit!
I feel like I'm covering a natural disaster!
Oh my god! Whats going on over there!?
Holy shit! They're going...
We fucking made it! We made it, were outside of the
DotA 2 lounge Suite 20 for r/DotA2
This mother fucker got us in. I told them I was
Arteezy and they believed me.
So ends our time at the VIP area.
The security, the scooter men got us.
iceiceice right here dropping bombs!
We're not filming you, don't worry the camera's not on
It's totally on, we fucking got him!
Slacks: So why you in line for dendi's autograph?
Fan: I'm his biggest fan!
Slacks: It was really eye-opening experience to be like,
ok this is what it's all about, this is this
world and it's kind of strange because
almost everybody that talk to in DotA 2
has a long legacy. They've all been there
since DotA 1, I  mean they've all been
working toward and as a guy that just
kind of just got there and got to see it
I feel like it was a little bit easier
for me to explain it to the masses as well
Slacks: DotA 2...
SUNSfan: Hey I played the original
SUNSfan: That's all that matters, right?
Slacks: Oh cool grandpa, tell me more about it.
Slacks: Alright, are you excited to be on
Team Slacks, Arteezy!?
Arteezy: Yeah.
(Crowd laughs)
Slacks: Ooooook...
Kaci: Now you know what I deal with.
Slacks: Ah this is my life now, alright.
People take DotA extremely seriously and while there is
a place for that, I think there's a lot of
room to have fun!
Slacks: Ok, come on Paul, you don't sound excited what
do you got a hand up your ass?
Come on, we're having a good time here.
I'm surprised that got past that section
thats a pretty big section right there.
It's a video game! We're gamers, we all enjoy
the same thing, we have fun, so let's have fun
together, that's kind of been my mission but...
I don't know, we'll see if it works.